all right so today I'm trying something
different this semester I wanted to tell
you guys about sort of one way that you
can discover things in biology and this
is gonna fall in sort of the genetics
cluster of lectures I want to show you
how you can go from being interested in
some property of an organism or even its
behavior how would you go from there to
identifying genes and mechanisms that
are responsible for that type of
behavior or appearance okay so today
we're gonna go from some type of
phenotype or a process that you're
interested in such as maybe the
appearance of an organism but you were
even going to go more abstract at that
because at the end I'm gonna tell you
about you can even if you're interested
in behavior you can try to figure out
the genes and mechanisms that are
involved in determining the behavior of
an organism okay so the question is how
do you go from something you're
interested in learning about an organism
to actually identifying genes and
mechanisms that are important for that
and on my title slide here I have three
fruit fly mutant phenotypes you can see
and each of these mutants defined genes
that were subsequently found to be
present or homologous genes were present
in humans and were shown to be play
important roles in human biology okay so
later on in the lecture I'll kind of
explain what each of these phenotypes is
but first I want to just kind of
highlight the importance of model
organisms and their use in biology
you've been seeing them already I've
talked a bit about flies we talked about
Mendel's pea plants
I just now have a compendium of model
organisms that I'm gonna throw up to
tell you about so we've talked about
bacteria and the importance of bacteria
in elucidating the flow of information
from DNA to RNA to protein bacteria were
also extremely important for elucidating
the initial mechanisms of gene
regulation okay I mentioned yeast a
little bit in the last lecture when I
mentioned tetrad analysis but we'll talk
about yeast a lot more later when we
start talking about the regulation of
cell division and the cell cycle because
yeast played a pivotal role in
identifying the gene that's critical for
this decision of a cell whether or not
to divide also one terrific model
organism in plants is a rabid abscess
thaliana and a rabid abscess has also
played an important role in elucidating
mechanisms of development but also in
making advances in scientific research
that relate to agriculture such as
disease resistance and host-pathogen
interactions okay so the two heroes of
today's lecture will be the round worm
see an arab Dittus elegans and the fruit
fly Drosophila melanogaster but before
getting into studies in those organisms
I wanted to highlight a couple important
vertebrate model organisms the zebrafish
and the mouse and so you can see the
mouse's is our lab mascot but it's also
an important genetic model in particular
there are many models and mice that
mimic cancer and so these have been
useful for elucidating mechanisms of
cancer i so it's really unethical for us
to do a lot of different types of
experiments on humans but i will mention
that there are human cell lines such as
the HeLa cell line and these also play
an important role in biology research
but these cell lines are taken out of
context right they're not functioning in
the context of an entire organism so
human cell lines are important but you
have to understand that they're they're
sort of an in vitro system that they're
out of the context of a functioning
organism okay so why is it that we
research these model organisms so there
are some practical reasons most of them
are fairly small and they're easy to
house large numbers of them in a lab
they're often cheap to to house in the
lab and work with also they a lot they
develop fast right and especially when
we consider genetics the rate limiting
step in genetics research is the time it
takes from the conception of an organism
to the time that that organism can
reproduce sexually okay so these model
organisms most of them reproduce very
quickly and so that accelerates the pace
of research okay but maybe most
importantly is the fact that we are
related to each of these model organisms
through evolution because we all arose
from a common ancestor okay and just to
highlight this example using the fruit
fly the fruit fly has 17,000 genes when
compared to our 20,000 genes so we have
roughly the same order of magnitude
number of genes as the fruit fly and so
let's let's think about important genes
let's think about just genes that are
associated with human diseases if we
just consider human disease-causing
genes 75% of the human disease-causing
genes have a homologous gene in the
fruit fly
okay so we're we're similar to these
model organisms such as the fruit fly in
particular genes that are important for
understanding human disease
so I came across this quote when
preparing for the lecture and I liked it
from John Wren who's a contemporary of
ours and John Rin said genetic
approaches are as fundamental to biology
as math is to physics and I think this
is an apt quote because both genetics
and math themselves are scientific
disciplines but they can be leveraged to
sort of learn things about biology and
physics respectively
okay so genetics really plays a
fundamental role in biology in the
discovery of new biological mechanisms
okay so now I want to just briefly take
you through how is it that we discover
things using genetics and I'm gonna take
you through a type of approach that's
called a forward genetic screen and I'll
get to the orchestra in just a minute
but I briefly just want to define what a
forward genetic screen is so when a
forward genetic screen is a type of
approach you would do if you don't know
the genes that are involved in a
specific process but you want to
identify them so in a forward genetic
screen you don't know the genes and
mechanisms involved so you don't know
what these genes are you might not even
have a genome sequence of the organism
you don't need a genome sequence in
order to do a forward genetic screen
because you don't know the genes but
you're interested in a particular aspect
of development or of organismal function
and you want to identify the genes that
are important for that so when starting
a forward genetic screen you have to
then infer what a possible phenotype
would look like if you broke genes that
were involved in that process so the
mantra of geneticists is that we are
going to break genes and then look at
the result right and see if it gives the
phenotype we're interested in
okay so in a forward genetic screen
you're looking for a phenotype that you
would expect if you affected a certain
process if you disrupt a process okay so
think about this Orchestra up here let's
say you are interested in what regulates
each of these sections in the orchestra
right what what is the master regulator
of this Orchestra if you will right and
so the conceptually what a genetic
screen would involve is taking hundreds
maybe thousands of orchestras like this
one and just shooting an individual in
this Orchestra and removing them from
the orchestra right and so you would
let's say you remove let's say you
remove this guy right here
then maybe nothing really happens
because they're like you know 30 or 40
other violinists and that's not the
major control circuit right so then you
would infer that this gene is not
important for the regulation of the
orchestra well let's say you took out
Bernstein right and then then you listen
to the orchestra and find that the
sections are uncoordinated there's you
know the bassist start doing crazy
things on their own so then in the logic
of Joseph's legend etics you would then
name that gene uncoordinated and infer
that that gene has some important role
in sort of coordinating the different
sections of the orchestra okay so the
the goal in genetics is to end up
identify a mutation that alters a gene
function that gives you a phenotype that
you're interested in and rather than
taking a gun and shooting members of the
orchestra in genetics you try to
identify mutations so you try to induce
mutations
okay so we're looking for mutations and
these mutations could be spontaneous
mutations meaning you didn't do anything
to induce it but they just appear as a
variant in the population and so we've
talked about Thomas Hunt Morgan and the
white mutant and the white gene so the
white mutant was a spontaneous mutation
Morgan's lab didn't do anything special
they just looked at lots of flies and
over the decades they identified this
one special male fly that they could
work on okay but nowadays researchers
have way to accelerate this process and
so we can induce mutations and the way
we can induce mutations is by using some
type of mutagen okay so for example you
could have some sort of chemical mutagen
that increases the error rate and deep
DNA replication or you could use
radiation to induce DNA damage and that
essentially accelerates the frequency of
mutations that occur in the genome of an
organism okay and so the process of
mutagen izing and organism isn't
specific to genes you're just inducing
random mutations across the genome of
the individual okay so if I took let's
say this piece I'm drawing here is part
of a chromosome and these boxes are
genes you're inducing random mutations
and maybe one mutation hits this gene
right so that's that's a mutation that
might affect the function of an organism
you might have other mutations that are
outside genes and may have no effect or
you could have a different kind of
mutation which isn't in the coding
region of the gene but maybe affects the
regulation of this blue gene over here
okay so this is a random process if
you're sort of feeding an organism some
chemical mutagen you're inducing random
mutations in different places and you
don't know which are the ones that you
you want until you look at their
phenotypes and try to find the needle in
the haystack okay so let me show you
some examples so let's say we were
interested in our body pattern right we
all have a body we are our head is in
our head position or asses in our ass
position we have arms that are in a
right position or legs are in the right
position right let's say we're
interested in figuring out what genes
were responsible for that body pattern
what kind of a mutants might you look
for anyone Rachel what's that a mutant
with his body parts in the wrong place
right you could get maybe you have like
a leg where your arm should be coming
out or maybe you have two heads or
something like that so you'd look for
some sort of defect in the pattern
formation and so this would be obviously
unethical to do in humans but in model
organisms we can actually find these
types of mutations I'm just gonna
highlight a couple mutants this one's an
obvious one so this fly has two wings
you can see them kind of folded over
each other right here but there's a
specific class of mutant that was called
wingless where the flies have fewer than
two wings this particular fly has only
one wing okay and this wingless mutant
defined a gene that became known as
wingless and is a it's a gene that has a
homologous gene in humans and this
particular gene defines an entire
signaling pathway which looks sorry
which is important in stem cell biology
and is also over activated in cancer
okay but obviously we don't have wings
so this gene didn't get discovered in
humans it was discovered in flies and
then only later on it was
inferred or was discovered that there's
a related gene in humans okay so that's
one example one of the other phenotypes
I showed you is called not normally a
fly wing has a nice smooth margin but
not music
chunk taken out of them at the end okay
so again the gene became known as notch
because of this fly phenotype but again
there's a human notch and human notch
again is involved in human diseases such
as cancer okay so that's two examples
but now I want to talk to you about how
one might find the needle in the
haystack how can you have a concerted
effort to identify genes that have the
function sort of in a given process I'm
going to tell you about work done by
Eric whish house and Christian new
slayin vole hard because they did one of
the more famous genetic screens that had
been done and they won the Nobel Prize
for their results in 1995 okay so I'm
going to take you through this classic
genetic screen and this is in this
screen they're going to induce mutations
so I'm gonna take a parental generation
and this screen was done using fruit
flies and they took male fruit flies and
treated the mouse with a mutagen to
induce mutations in the gametes of these
dis mal these mal flies that would then
be passed to subsequent generations pay
and they mated the mutagenize mouths to
females and then they went on to look at
to isolate individual f1 progeny so
we're gonna look at individual f1
progeny in this generation so in the f1
the f1 progeny have the potential to get
one mutagenize chromosome from their
father and we'll get a normal chromosome
from the mother okay so I'll just draw
this like this we're independent
mutations are going to be different
colors
so that has maybe a mutation on one of
its chromosomes another fly because this
is random might have a different
mutation on the same or a different
chromosome I'll draw a couple more maybe
one of these flies doesn't have a
mutation that's been induced and then
I'll draw just one independent mutation
right there
okay so again this is random so to see
random mutations you have to take
individual flies now are you gonna see a
phenotype in this f1 generation so miles
is it Malik or miles sorry miles good
okay
[Music]
exactly so what miles just said is that
basically he said that these mutations
if they're loss-of-function mutations
are going to be recessive because
they're going to be overshadowed by a
normal functioning gene on the other
chromosome right so if you're looking
for a loss-of-function mutation that's
likely going to be recessive and you
would not see it in the f1 generation
okay so in order to look for organisms
that have incorrect incorrect body
patterning you need to get a situation
where each of the mutated chromosomes is
homozygous recessive okay and to do that
you have to do more crosses so what the
researchers did was to take independent
organ individual organisms and cross
them all again to non-mutated flies and
remember flies don't south cross so they
need a male and a female that has the
same mutated chromosome mating to each
other in order to see a recessive
phenotype so because you only have an
individual fly for each of these you
need to get more than one fly with the
same mutation so they may - to a normal
fly but now you can get in the F to
multiple f2 males and females that will
have the same mutated chromosome okay so
here let's draw these
okay so with the still still
heterozygous at this point but at this
point you just generated multiple
organisms now and female to have the
same chromosome that arose from
essentially the same chromosome and the
father okay
the male gamete in the parental
generation see oh I did green okay okay
so now we have mouths and females both
of which are heterozygous and you know
I'm skipping some of the details of this
cross just you'll have to take my word
for the fact that they can keep track of
which chromosome is which and I'm not
going to tell you how they did that
because it's kind of like fly genetics
and it's not terribly important that you
know it but just so now you have males
and females and now you can look in f3
and from each of these lines each of
these lines you're going to cross
siblings to each other so you're doing a
sibling cross what fraction of the
progeny for each of these sibling
crosses should be homozygous for the
mutant chromosome yes Steven 1/4 exactly
right so Stevens Stevens exactly right a
quarter of the progeny should get two
copies of the mutated chromosome so 25
percent should be homozygous recessive
and so you can screen this f3 progeny
for each of these independent lines and
look for flies at some stage of
development that are defective in
patterning okay and so I'll show you how
where my clicker go all right so they're
looking for ink rock correct body
pattern so if you yes your question
what's your name again
Georgia yeah
[Music]
No
yes so they're able to select for the
mutated chromosome yeah
and I'm skipping over how they did that
because it's kind of I so tarik but
you're right some would be normal but
they I'm just telling you they're able
to figure out the ones that have the
mutant chromosome and they made sure to
keep those in the next generation okay
good question Georgia alright so they
can screen at three for a phenotype it
turns out all of the mutations they're
interested in are lethal so they have to
look at the larval stages for ones that
have a defect in patterning so this is
what a Drosophila larvae looks like and
you can see it has this segmented
pattern here this is the head of the
larvae the tail of the larvae but you
see there are these segments that
alternate between smooth cuticle and
hairy cuticle they have things called
denticles which are these hairlike
projections which are essentially what
the maggot uses for traction so it can
crawl around okay so they're basically
just looking at maggots here and looking
at the pattern of segments in the
maggots okay but what they found is a
mutant here's the mutant here which just
has these hairlike projections all
across the cuticle without these
intervening regions of naked cuticle
okay and because it's there's a lot of
like hairlike projections here it
reminded the researchers of a hedgehog
and so this mutant became known as
Hedgehog and the Hedgehog gene was the
founding member of an entire signaling
pathway known as the hedgehog pathway
that plays important roles in human
development and also human cancer so the
human gene for Hedgehog or one of the
most important ones in humans is known
as sonic hedgehog so you see that the
geneticists have kind of an odd sense of
humor
so but the sonic hedgehog gene is
important in cancer and actually there
are now a number of drugs that are being
developed to target the hedgehog pathway
and one was approved back in 2012 for
use in treating basal
carcinoma and there's currently another
drug that's in phase two clinical trials
for treating some forms of leukemia okay
so this is a story that goes from
identifying this weird fly mutant all
the way to clinical trials developing
drugs that are whose purpose is to
inhibit this signaling pathway which
Hedgehog is the signal the extracellular
ligand for okay so now I'm gonna switch
gears and tell you about another story
it's a bit like this one except this one
has an MIT connection so I'm going to
tell you about work done at MIT in the
worm see an Arab Titus elegans and this
work was done in the lab of Robert
Horvitz who was a member of our biology
department and Robert Horvitz for his
work won the Nobel Prize along with john
sulston and Sydney Brenner Brenner for
their work on how cells decide what
fates they give rise to and specifically
and one thing that the Horvitz lab has
done is to elucidate the mechanisms that
determine whether or not a cell lives or
dies during development okay so if we
think about the development of an
organism we all start from a single cell
and this thing these cells the cell
divides into different cells but
different cells in our body give rise to
different cell fates okay so if we
consider just a generic cell division
here you have a parent cell a it might
divide into cell be and cell C and maybe
cell B might have a particular fate it
might go on to develop into a neuron or
a muscle cell whatever it doesn't matter
right but one fate that
that Horvitz Alston and Brenner saw is
that sometimes cells
their fate was to just die okay and this
was very stereotypic you get a death
okay and this was defined as programmed
cell death because it followed a very
stereotypic where the same cell each
time would undergo cell death okay so it
seems like there's a program for it
this also is called apoptosis so what
really enabled this work is the biology
of C elegans and here I'm showing you C
elegans development this is the C
elegans zygote this cell divides into
two cells that are different one is
called a B one is called p1 and we know
exactly what the fates for the
descendants of both these cells are
based on the work of Saul Steinbrenner
and Horvitz
now you get a four cell stage where a B
divides into two cells and p1 divides
into two cells and a gun we know the
fates of all these cells and what what C
elegans researchers have done because C
elegans is a relatively simple organism
there are only 947 cells in every
individual worm so they're 947 somatic
cells and this is stereotypic every worm
has these 947 cells okay how many cells
do you have more than or less than 1,000
you have more than 1,000 cells right
that makes you much more complicated
right so really the practical aspect of
C elegans is it has a much simpler
composition and they can track what
happens to every single one of these
cells they know when every cell divides
and what the daughter cells of that
division will turn into
in other words they know the entire
lineage of this animal okay so this is a
picture of the lineage that's showing
you what happens to every single cell in
the development of an adult worm
okay and so what particularly interested
robert Horvitz is 131 cells during the
development of this animal underwent
programmed cell death okay and this is
not random cell death it's the same
cells every time right they know what
happens to every single cell in the
development of this organism so they
know when there's a division in one
specific cell dies every time in the
organism okay so it's really a unique
scenario where you can really see what
becomes of every cell that is present in
the organism okay so now let's talk a
little bit about the death process so
that I'll make the cell death process
simple you start with a live cell okay
so you have a live cell that live cell
dies such that you then have a dead cell
and then after the cell dies after the
cell dies the remnants of that dead cell
are engulfed by neighboring cells such
that you no longer have you no longer
see that cell so the last step in this
process is engulfment now a key aspect
of one of Horvitz is screens is that
other researchers had identified a
mutation that affected cell death that
specifically blocked this engulfment
process okay and this gene is called
said one is the first cell death mutant
that was identified said stands for cell
death abnormal
hey so CED short for said so so
researchers in the C elegans field
started isolating these cell death
abnormal mutants where something
happened in the cell death process that
was abnormal okay and I'll tell you why
how this was leveraged by the Horvitz
lab to identify basically a pathway of
genes that were involved in cell death
so this is now a worm and what you see
in this worm are these bubble like
structures that are cells that are dead
but haven't been engulfed okay so these
these dead cells because they're not
engulfed are visible in the adult worm
and so you can basically just look at
adult worms and see whether or not these
bubble like structures are present okay
and it said one mutant in a wild-type
worm you don't see this and so it's
harder to see but this provided a visual
assay to look for mutations that block
the cell death process because if you
block the process upstream of said one
and engulfment you no longer will see
these bubble like structures okay and so
that is what the Horvitz lab did they
started with said one mutant worms so
they're starting with the said one
mutant and they then mutagenize these
said one mutants sorry mutagenize and so
they're essentially looking for second
mutants in this animal that will affect
the bretton the death process okay I'll
take you through the logic of this so
for the remainder of the generations I'm
going to tell you about they're all said
one mutant okay so because this said one
said one is homozygous in this case
and worms are hermaphrodites meaning
they have both male and female sex
organs and therefore they can self
fertilize so this is a self cross and so
said one remains homozygous mutant
throughout all these crosses okay now
similar to the flyscreen they they can
look for individual or they can you get
individual worms here just get some
colors so we can compare different
chromosomes right so this chromosome
might have one mutants this chromosome
could have another mutant and this
chromosome could have another mutant and
maybe this one doesn't have a mutant
okay but again these are heterozygous
animals so if you're looking for a
loss-of-function mutant you would not
see the phenotype at this stage okay so
what was done in this screen is because
these are worms and they're
hermaphrodites they basically allowed
each of these worms to self cross so now
we're talking just about a self cross
and because this the individual a single
worm has just one of these chromosomes
when it undergoes a self cross part of a
quarter of the progeny will be
homozygous recessive for the mutation
okay so here we have the f1 generation
and now they can just look at the f2
generation and they're looking for some
fraction of the worms resulting from
each individual that has a phenotype
that looks like a cell death mutant
phenotype
okay and so they're essentially going to
screen through the f2 generation and
look for worms that fail to have these
bubble like structures in the adult worm
okay so they're looking for a loss of
these refract isle structures okay and
they got one this mutant this is now a
double mutant between said one and said
three and you see how you no longer have
these big bubble like structures in the
worm okay so they identified a mutant
and thus a gene that's called said three
which which basically causes a failure
of the cells to undergo cell death now
given what I've given what I've shown
you is this necessarily a mutant that's
involved in cell death can you think of
an alternative explanation for why you
would lose these sort of bubble like
structures what else could be happening
you know when you do a screen like this
and we'd use science and generate gen in
general you have to think through all
the different types of possibilities
yes Georgia
excellent Georgia said you could have
remute ated said one right so one
possibility is that you isolated a said
one reverting which means you changed
its you changed its DNA sequence so that
now the said one gene is functional okay
so one scenario here is you could have
you could have some type of revert --nt
or you could have a suppressor mutation
maybe you have a mutation that
suppresses bypasses the function of said
one such that now that the cells can
engulf the dead cell okay so you could
also have the suppressor Okura or the
alternative scenario the one we that we
want is that we've affected the cell
death process and identified something
that is a bonafide cell death mutant how
would you differentiate between these
two any ideas
should this have an extra cell no it
Stephen says no I agree there should be
no extra cell here right because if you
restored the phagocytic process then the
cell should die it should be engulfed
and there shouldn't be an extra cell but
what if this is a bonafide cell death
mutant then you should have extra cells
and it turns out the said three mutant
blocks all 131 of these cell deaths so
that you have a hundred thirty-one extra
cells right because they know the entire
cell lineage of this worm and can see
whether or not cells are present or not
they can tell if there are extra cells
or not and therefore that allowed them
to infer that they had an actual mutant
that was affecting the mechanism by
which that promotes the cell to die okay
and this shows that this cell death it
shows that cell death is an active
process it's not
just some random event that's happening
is an active process that is controlled
by genes okay
so there's an active mechanism involved
in the cell death okay any questions
about sort of how these like screens go
and the crosses before I move on okay so
I have one more story to tell you about
and this relates to behavior okay so now
I want to tell you about behavior all
right we all behave some of us better
than others so so how is it we can go
from something as abstract as behavior
to specific genes and mechanisms that
control this okay and I'm going to tell
you about work that was awarded the
Nobel Prize last year two of these
researchers their careers are at
Brandeis and so what they discovered as
the mechanisms that controls circadian
rhythm in organisms
okay so circadian rhythm so circadian
rhythm is a behavior right we are awake
during certain parts of the day and RS
in our sleep at night and if we are so
if you're hidden from the light-dark
cycle you continue this cycle for some
amount of time okay so there's something
intrinsic in our system such that we
sort of want to exist on this 24-hour
wake sleep cycle okay that's why it's a
pain in the ass to travel to the other
side of the world
okay so how can we identify so we want
to identify sort of what controls this
behavior what then might be a phenotype
you might look for
what would happen if you break circadian
rhythm yeah Rachel it wouldn't have a
nice clear wake sleep cycle exactly so
the screen what they did is to look at
look for flies that where they didn't
have this robust wake sleep cycle okay
so you basically look for flies that are
like awake at night and identify the
mutations that cause this to happen okay
I'll show you an example of what the
data looks like
so what each of these lines is is each
tick mark is a measurement of fly
activity so what you see our flies sleep
they're awake they're asleep they're
awake okay and a researchers identified
mutants that didn't show this 24-hour
cycle so some are just totally a
rhythmic other mutants alter the period
of this cycle so that it's either longer
or shorter okay so this is a really
elegant way to look for genes that are
important for circadian rhythm I'll take
you through the genetic screen this was
done by Konopka and Benzer and they did
a nice they did a nice screen it
involves a genetic trick which I'll show
you there's a type of chromosome called
attached X and flies where two X
chromosomes are fused to each other so
two x chromosomes fused
and if a fly has two x-chromosomes as
female if it just has one x chromosome
it's now okay so that's how fly that's
what determines fly gender so then these
researchers took males and mutagenize
them and they cross these males to
attach to X females and when you cross
nails to attach next X females you do
something clever which is half of the
progeny dies because you need an X
chromosome and you can't have three x
chromosomes but your females are all
attached to X Y so the females actually
get their X chromosomes from their mom
which is the opposite of the way it
normally works and the males get their X
chromosome from dad okay because the
attached X train has a Y chromosome okay
so this is a little bit of a genetic
trick and the fly the reason it was done
in this case is they wanted to mutate
the X chromosome and then have the
father's pass on their X chromosome to
their sons because there's only one copy
of the X chromosome so if you get a
mutation on X you don't have to
homozygote homozygotes it because
there's only one copy of it okay
so it's a little bit of a genetic trick
that in this case serve the researchers
a generation on their screen okay so you
take this and then you identify males
now that have a mutated x chromosome and
they have only one x chromosome so that
they should be able to observe the
behavior even here okay but to establish
a line of flies that have this mutation
they then took these f1 mutated males
and cross them again to attached X flies
and again in doing this all the males
from this cross are mutant so now you
have multiple males all of which are
mutant
so you can start with a single now f1
and by crossing it to this strain here
you get a lot of males now that have the
mutant chromosome and you can look at
their behavior to determine whether
you've affected circadian rhythm okay
does everyone understand how the
attached X works here it's kind of a
little bit of a trick but you know flies
have these tools that you can use to to
save you time in the lab okay so these
mutants that the the Benzer lab
identified had altered period of the
sleep/wake cycle and therefore the gene
was named period okay so this screen
identified a gene called period this is
a gene and there's a homologue of the
period gene in humans okay and the gene
in humans is associated with familial
advanced sleep phase syndrome
okay so defects in the genes that were
identified in in Drosophila actually are
relevant to human sleep disorders okay
all right I'm all set
you